the Joe Rogan experience CrossFit let's
see it's a circle back around to that
what do they do that you feel you said
there's a lot of good things they do
they get people moving they introduce
people to all these different exercise
routines what do you think they do wrong
Joe I don't want to pick on CrossFit
this so called metabolic conditioning
has been around since 1975 at least when
Arthur Jones coined that term you know
the guy from Nautilus mm-hmm
that's when he would people go through a
circuit of machines going you know going
one after the next and I'm sure it's
been around even before that I would
just do things totally different so
there is no point in there's no point in
me trying to criticize criticize a
different system I'm just telling you
this is what the science says experience
says is how you should be doing it
mm-hmm and I think that there are a lot
of great people in CrossFit and I just
wish you know power to them you would
just do it the what like what you're
talking about with longer rest periods
different sort of training approach and
okay let's say that you're training for
the CrossFit Games
okay I'd say that's your goal right what
you would do is name some CrossFit
exercise let's say wall ball okay let's
have the throw the ball against the wall
good exercise you do this thing with
this wall ball for 40 minutes like I
told you and you can incorporate a
second exercise in between Dustin
between stick it in there so let's say
you do a wall ball you throw this a few
times walk around you do a set of
push-ups let's say 5 to 10 reps and you
do this for 40 minutes
why 40 minutes it doesn't always have to
be 40 minutes but pretty much we know if
you can sustain it for 40 minutes it's
not gonna be over the glycolytic so we
just kind of know that I'll give you
another example let's say burpees right
you can do a burpee but time it in a way
that you can keep doing burpees for 40
minutes so you do a wrap walk around do
a wrap walk around or even break it up
so you do this different across fit
specific competition specific exercises
in this particular manner were you able
to sustain it again for 40 minutes then
part me closer to the competition you
start doing what in track is called
peaking so when you're running let's say
400 meters or 800 meters athletes when
they train in the offseason the Train
largely aerobic ly even though their
distances are shorter they're still not
trying to trash themselves but we do
know that even if you develop your
mitochondria if you do it correctly and
suddenly you throw yourself in an acid
bath your body is gonna be unpleasantly
surprised so what you need to do is you
need to model that so what's going to
happen is a couple of weeks before the
competition once a week you were pretty
much it's like a something similar to
the competition like a water whatever
and this will accomplish several things
one is it will up regulate your buffers
so your body produces baking soda pretty
much to cancel out the acid and it's a
very rapid adaptation it's very easy to
get just two weeks you got it and in
addition you also up regulates your
glycolytic enzymes which you also want
for competition and again they're very
quick to develop very quick to lose as
well so finally there is such a thing as
heart and respiration rate modelling so
which pretty much means that you're
gonna be sucking win and if you're not
used to sucking win it's not gonna feel
good your diaphragm is gonna spasm and
not so good so the purpose of peaking is
to get yourself in kind of a simulated
competition situation where the acid is
high enough to make your body adapt to
it which adapts fast and to make
yourself comparable with Hari high heart
rates and breathing so that's that's the
summary that's pretty much how track
athletes train
[Applause]